Yeah. I don't want to watch that
Michael Jackson thing. First of all,
it's weird. Come on. Not Alive. He's
not allowed to defend themselves.
So it's weird.
It's also stories and you know,
people tell the truth in stories
sometimes and sometimes they don't and you
don't know. You don't know. And, and also
there was, you know, it was always weird.
Like people,
no one knew why with all the rumors that
everybody had ever heard about Michael
Jackson, that anybody would let
their kids go and hang out with him.
Like when you watched your documentary,
like these parents are fucking moron.
I don't get it, man. Two of the
fathers have committed suicide since.
Oh
Christ.
We don't have any hard. Oh,
it was molesting kids. Right.
All we have is rumors. Well,
here's the thing. He was
acquitted. Here's the problem.
The doctor, his very doctor said
that he was chemically castrates.
I'm not the guy who
killed them. Yes. Yeah.
That guy said he was chemically castrated
by his parents to protect his voice.
You have no testosterone. Right, exactly.
Not just no testosterone. The units,
I mean me,
I don't think so.
One of the other weird things I saw that
was like facts. You should hear it. No,
from the documentary was that he had uh,
some something to do with
the sound in the room.
The hallway leading up to his bedroom was
wired so that footprint's would make a
ding dong sound in the room.
It's just a very strange thing to
just have in general for any purpose.
But if you grow up in the spotlight,
because remember he was such a big star,
you might have some anxiety,
right?
Maybe he didn't want anybody walking in
and I'm a naked or something or he don't
want anyone walking in while,
yeah, touching boys could be that.
Look who the fuck we don't know. We don't
know. However, what do you think Jamie?
I know,
I'm just saying some of the facts.
I remember he spent like 30 straight
nights with like a 12 year old at his,
at his house in between that kid's
mom's house in his dad's house.
We're divorced and there's some
paying for somebody's video.
There's so much video of him
in this little boy holding
hands and the boy in the
video goes, yeah, we would
hold hands and we had a signal,
we'd rub each other's poems when we
were thinking sexually about each other.
However you got to chalk
it up to the shitty pants.
Cause if John Legend came to my house
it was like, dude, I love tiger.
You mind if I take him out for a little
while but get your God damn mind you're
not going well not only that and John
Legend's not a pedophile is not known but,
but they didn't know Michael Jackson was
that everybody knew there was something.
I'm not at the time he was the
biggest star in the world back then.
And the people in the nineties
I everybody knew something was really,
he was always hanging around with the
kids. Yeah. Cause he loved Dale Young.
Younger than us. You gotta
trust me anywhere. Sure.
Let's say month on something was up that
yet Jamie's more on the ball then you
saw he's always online. You're out
getting pussy James Online. The chip,
the chip point look too well.
Well played, sir. Well played.
I just feel like it's too weird.
It's too weird to let your kids
hang out with this grown man.
All those times he was mentally ill. They
and what his family says, they go, no, no.
A lot of you, you're confusing
him for being, he didn't
have a childhood. His Dad,
Robert with his child.
I think that's true inside.
He felt like he was nine years old,
so he missed out on the
sleepovers in video games,
so he would get friends with
kids and I think loud on.
It's batshit crazy,
batshit crazy.
I think all those things
that you're saying are true,
but I also think it's true that he
was probably chemically castrated.
I really think that's true because I've
said that a long time ago. I said, yeah,
I think he's a cast. Trato
the waste, his voice is
telling that it's human nature kid.
That voice is just not a man's voice.
She's not even a false settled. Yep.
A woman's voice castrated.
Then when he would have zero
testosterone to molest kids,
while he might not have been
doing it because he was Horny,
he might've been doing it
because he was just weird. Well,
these kits as he was busted nuts,
the kids in the video said like you
would jack himself off in front of them.
Boy It,
it'll make you sick to your stomach.
Not his wife,
but the woman that gave birth to his two
kids said she'd never had sex with him.
Yeah,
that's more likely.
If you're chemically castrated,
that means your body doesn't
produce any testosterone anymore.
But it doesn't mean you can't shoot it
into your body and you know you could,
you could shoot, test into your
body if you have no net not,
you're not making seaman.
Yeah, have your balls are dead,
but you isn't seeming or
[inaudible] a sperms from the nuts.
And then like your prostate and I,
some other things that
get the juice together.
So not a doctor.
Clearly
the whole thing is fucking super weird.
It's swab weird. It just makes me sad.
It makes me so sad. But it's
also, there's like a, there's a,
there's a lesson to be learned
there in so many different ways,
but one of the big lessons to be learned
is that you never want to be that
famous. That, that was my
takeaway. I was watching my grind.
I go, can you imagine being that famous?
And she goes, yeah, it's probably awesome.
But no, hold on. You know how we like
to go to the mall? We go out to eat.
That's gone. You can't do that anymore.
That's all gone. It's all gone.
People would book, but they'll
start a riot. So take that,
take that away from your
normal life is not over.
You just stay in your house. But yeah,
that's why he developed an amusement park.
Like he made his house,
I'll fucking amusement park.
They had, they set this up for him to
go grocery shopping. They had a fake,
the empty the grocery store and paid
people to be a shoppers so he could have
the experience of what
it's like to be normal.
Going through like a Ralph's or
whatever. Yeah. People like, hey,
how's it [inaudible]
some bread. See how weird this is. Well,
they should make it so we hired people,
we could do that and he wore
a hat and he's dancing around.
It's, everything was weird man. Everything
was going to feel bad for him though.
Oh yeah. So we know how
much he was worth. I Dunno.
One point $7 billion they say,
but that's after he died. It see,
the thing is when he died,
he got super rich.
He was actually in the hole
before he died. No, because,
because it wasn't tour hammer broke.
Where when he talked to MCM, he's like,
what are you talking about? He's
like, there's like, you know,
publicists broke where they released that
he'd go bankrupt and he was, I was fun.
I was balling,
I think it was Michael Jackson.
He owned the Beatles catalog. Oh. So
that's where he had all his money.
He bought all the originals. The
masters of his and the beetle. Yeah.
Paul Mccartney was mad
about that apparent. He told
him. He gave me the idea.
Paul gave me idea. Good
idea. I'll be right back.
So why question Paul by it. He's
got money. You can afford it.
Here's one fourth of the Beatles money.
Not all of it combined. You know,
do think health condition.
There's no stars like Michael
Jackson. You can't write,
can't do it in the
current society there's,
there's pockets now in happy
birthday he owned happy birthday.
He bought the rights to it.
So that's why you weren't,
you're not allowed to sing it
in a restaurant that's over.
I think you can say it and they can now
cause it's back into the public domain.
That's why everyone's sinks a bullshit.
Happy Birthday. Happy, happy birthday.
Happy, happy, happy times.
ASCAP or BMI could literally come
in and just find the restaurant.
If you were saying Shit, cause I'm
Michael. That's so stupid. Dude.
Watteau ball or move with copyright owning
happy birthday. I went out of money.
Too bad he doesn't like bitches cause
that'd be the biggest movie ever.
Maybe just like it just, who
knows. Know the guy's dead.
He can't have some respect shop.
Here's the thing,
those two dudes who are doing it,
they were,
one was the key witness when he
got away in court. What dudes?
The dudes in the documentary,
the two, oh, we got molested.
The one was the number one key witness
who is saying he didn't get them listed.
Okay, well then you shouldn't be able
to say anything. Both of them were,
because that means they should go to
jail. And now they're like, well, no,
that's not true. We were young bitch,
you were twice. Well also like,
isn't that perjury? It means
he lied in court. Be fucked.
You can't lie in court either way,
one way or the other.
You can't lie to protect somebody and
you can't lie to accuse someone either.
You can't lie. I don't know
what the deal is. I mean,
that seems like that's something
they could drag him to court for it.
And the Jackson came out, went,
well, isn't it convenient?
You guys are coming out now when you're
in financial trouble? Uh, of course.
Yeah,
of course.